Travis Kelce we just saw on the TV
outside we did fizer advert but I guess
if you're hanging out the back of Taylor
Swift what do you care you know what I
mean I yeah well okay so we just saw
what what happened to you when you saw
that it's just kind of it's so strange
to see someone that has so much status
and kind of embodies a lot of like
rebellious nature which I think you know
football players QB's that like Alpha
masculine thing fisa I mean fisa's brand
Equity it's like it's it's hardly cool
what's the price what's the price that
makes it worth it what's the price to
someone like Travis Kelce that makes it
worth it for guys like you to go oh come
on you got domed by a Pharma company one
Taylor Swift
[__] so here's the [__] do you
think dating her is what influenced him
to do it get you think being attracted
to girls that skinny is a vaccine
injury you were saying before we got
started that there's been a a big push
body positivity we need diversity Barbie
movie comes out and Taylor Swift makes a
billion dollars on tour it's like it's
just [__] na Germany all over girls
are back than God Aran W dream um no I
so here's the real [__] conspiracy
right the real conspiracy
is Travis Kelce and Taylor Swift's
relationship was orchestrated by big
farmer because they started dating at
the same time that he did that fisa
campaign so search volume for Travis
Kel's name went through the roof and
when you search for his name the vaccine
stuff and the fiser partnership comes up
too so my question about that it's like
my same thing about aliens and stuff
it's like I just think people are so
weak and so desperate to like talk to
her girl at a bar or get attention or
the wrong person involved in that
Scandal took Edibles don't you think
someone would have gotten fired and told
people about it oh right it's like with
the aliens it's like someone would have
snitched someone one some guy would have
gotten drunk at a bar and been like hey
like you don't want to go home with me
you want to see a picture of a [__]
alien you know what I'm saying like
don't you think it would have gotten
out yeah I mean coordination is
difficult and there's definitely Two
Worlds that people are able to hold in
their mind at once which is the
government is both so incompetent that
they can't organize a piss up in a
brewery and so competent that they're
able to orchestrate this sort of in Viet
I'm like if they were aliens we would
have known okay like we would absolutely
know by now well maybe the beginning and
end of their capability is orchestrating
a Travis Kelsey Taylor Swift
relationship I don't know it's weird I
also think though you know who who's she
going to date that's the thing who's she
GNA date he it seems like guys will date
down all day you know but who's she GNA
date who's the Jay-Z to her Beyonce yeah
rough one I uh do you know meet Canyon
he does illustration videos on the
internet really really great guy and I
thought you were talking about my my
child birth thing come on come on I'm
sorry I'm sorry two and a half minutes
in and talking about your meat Canyon
anyway he's got a channel called Papa
meat and on it he reacted to Swifty Tik
toks and it was girls um crying breaking
down crying because they The Ticket
Master website had shut down after
they'v been waiting for six hours okay
great um there was this one where it
broke down the finances I think Taylor
Swift's already beaten Michael Jackson
for the most revenue generated from a
tour it's I think at the moment 3 of a
billion dollars this tour is lasting for
nearly two years it's monstrous okay
well she's done a genius thing she's got
kids and I I'm she kids her fans her
fans sorry she's not a mother but she
appeals to children in a way that I
think so many and I'm sure we'll wait
into this territory in some capacity
where so many female pop stars it's all
about being hypersexualized
hypersexualized and like you know I'm
having a a boy when I you know have a
kid but it's like there's certain you're
like I can't let let my kid watch I
can't let my kid listen to this she's
done this genius thing where not only
that have you seen her dancing I
actually when I get into the conspiracy
theories you know I think she's very
mindful about not being too overtly
sexual dials that back the way that if
you look at how she dances she's like
bad at dancing it's not sexy it's like
awkward she looks like one of those
balloon men outside of a car dealership
waving inflatable fling CH she kind of
just is like sort of awkward and weird
there's never any sexuality about it
there's never any singing about sex it's
always just like getting your
heartbroken in these kind of relatively
like Teenage feelings and I think she's
done a really like genius job of that
well I think in a world of Sam Smith
wearing nipple tassels and dressing as
the devil the the original cult culture
is the counterculture right like if you
want to predict the future what you
should do is look at a movement that's
happening now that hasn't had the
inverse happen yet CU every culture
requires the equal and opposite thing
right it's like the thermodynamics of
[__] culture so
um 2020 everyone's shut down no one can
go outside 2021 Megan D stallion does
hot girl summer which is last year you
weren't able to be your free self this
year get with your girlfriends and do
your hair and do your makeup wet ass
[__] was around that time too maybe
they could have come together and then
the year after that they did feral girl
summer so you had hot girl summer and
then and feral girl summer was uh you
know don't shave don't brush your hair
wear slouchy sweatpants don't bother
with boys yeah for every culture there
has to be counterculture and if you've
got Sam Smith doing his thing you know
Taylor Swift looks like a [__]
conservative icon she does comparatively
and then I think that's part of the
reason I mean country music is also so
big because country music for the most
part is it's kind of like older women
they're wearing like boots and pants you
know where and then you have Katie Perry
with like cupcakes on her tits you know
it's kind of like um I think country
music in general parents feel safer
letting their kids listen to it and
going into shows it's a little more
innocent yeah but what's the worst thing
that's going to happen you're going to
be an alcoholic and and get in a car
wreck in a truck and yeah and yeah and a
man might wear a square toe boot which
is a big problem for me that's a large
yeah I mean I see that a lot in in
Austin Texas yeah yeah but yeah the um
this meat counting video Papa on his
second Channel Papa meet he's reacting
to all of these things and she I didn't
know but she released a movie in cinemas
yeah yeah yeah girls are losing their
[__] mindes with these um bracelets
no like a a baton like an LED thing
waving it around and then the credits
were rolling and girls were holding
hands dancing in a circle underneath the
[__] screen it is they're losing
their mind I I mean I didn't know she's
our Star Wars they have little
lightsabers that's true this is Star
Wars for girls but she also is very it's
these very easy to understand like girl
boss anthems you know what I mean and
something she did do do that cuz I I've
you don't know that much about her like
music per se I've worked with a bunch of
people that are obsessed with her she
does write all of her own stuff which is
very cool she's not one of these like
industry plants where she's got 15
writers and you go you know she really
does write it herself um and seems like
she plays all the music herself and she
the way that she engages her fans she
makes them feel really special I feel
like this is something we can learn from
you do an amazing job at engaging your
fans but like she leaves little little
Easter eggs for that and she like really
thinks her albums out in a way and
leaves these like puzzle pieces for them
and these codes and and sends gifts to
fans if they've come to a certain amount
of shows like she's really like done
this marketing thing that I think a lot
of us would think is kind of like corny
and I would I'd be embarrassed like I'd
be like oh if you like me you like me if
you don't you don't I'm not gonna send
I'm Not Gon to do a mailing list it's
like oh she did like what Tim Ferris did
she like built up a mailing list and
engaged with her fans and like and was
okay with going I want this really badly
like she was okay with being like I want
to be really famous and successful it
wasn't like if you like me you like me
if you don't you don't you know as a way
to control if I get rejected at least it
wasn't you know Mya but she did this one
thing where she got called a snake
because she um I don't know what it was
there was like all these snake emojis
either someone cheated on someone in
some kind of like you know Taylor swiv
gossip and someone asked her in an
interview they said so what do you feel
about the fact that so many people
online call you a snake and she went
well snakes eat
rats and I was like that that's pretty
gangster like I see why girls like look
up to her every time people come for her
she manages to sublimate it into
something else I think Elon Musk did
something similar where he got popped
for getting one of his staff at SpaceX
or Tesla pregnant and he just reacted to
the Tweet by saying the the world's
birth rights are declining I need to do
my bit like the [__] Brazilian
jiu-jitsu lexical [__] trickery that
you've just done there she stunts on
every time they come for her she stunts
on them somehow and I think so much of
our job as forward facing people now is
figuring out how to handle haters or
like how to not respond or you can't not
respond at all you know but you can't
care too much but she just kind of owns
it and then she'll put it into her songs
I think wit is such an underrated skill
just being able to be witty with with
stuff and you can be charming and not
give it too much UND attention
interesting that look at this the
[__] Taylor Swift podcast one like
definitely an interesting lesson there
about the fact that she was prepared to
do things that other artists of even a
smaller size would feel might be beneath
them or might be like low status it's
what I think in the psychology
literature would be called a counter
signal so um if you look at CEOs now
they'll happily wear Crocs or sneakers
or whatever and a hoodie into the office
but the guy who's a middle manager
that's desperately climbing he'll have
to wear a three-piece suit of course so
it's almost like she can afford to do
this because of her excess um every
single morning for over 3 years now I've
started my day the exact same way which
is with element in water element
contains a science-backed electrolyte
ratio of sodium potassium and magnesium
and it is the best hydration drink that
I've ever found it tastes fantastic it's
super refreshing orange is just the most
OP flavor in the world it's absolutely
phenomenal and it helps to play a
critical role in reducing muscle cramps
and fatigue it regulates your appetite
it optimizes brain health and it helps
curb Cravings they're also the exclusive
hydration partner to Team USA
weightlifting and relied on by tons of
Olympic athletes and everyday High
performers all around the world also
there is a no BS no questions asked
refund policy where you can buy a box
completely risk-free and if you do not
like it for any reason they will give
you a refund during an unlimited
duration and you don't even need to
return the box that's how confident they
are that you love it element are giving
away a free sample pack of all eight
flavors with your first box if you go to
the link in the description box below or
drink LM nt.com
MW that's drink LM n.com SL MW what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to
subscribe